to introduce Supporting Actor
ladies and gentlemen Miss Tatum O'Neal
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Thank You mr. Pryor I guess they asked
me to present this award for Best
Supporting Actor because I've been
supported by an actor on my life which
he keeps me of course I'm not the only
girl in Hollywood who's been supported
by an actor although my relationships a
little different
before I announce tonight's nominees I
must say that in all my years in
Hollywood I have never seen him
outstanding list of candidates the
actors nominated for performance in a
supporting role are Ned Beatty in
network burgess Meredith and Rocky
Laurence Olivier in Marathon Man
Jason Robards and all the presidents man
Burt young in Rocky
and the winner is Jason Robards and all
the favor
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm holding that right beautiful thank
you very much for the honor of the
nomination and also the honor of this
award I just want to say that I take
this in honor for my producer Robert
Redford who and my great fellow actor
who showed such integrity honesty and
perseverance in this project and in
honor of Alan Pakula our director and
also Ben Bradley for being alive so that
he would let me come out and play with
him thank you very much
[Music]